you
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
laureates ladies and gentlemen the
audence to grata at for present era
Nobel Prize targeting facility it is a
great honor to introduce the Nobel
laureate in physics professor and Roy
guy
hello everyone
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
ladies and gentlemen's colleagues and
friends a lot of praise has already been
given to our work this week and the
exciting new material graphene we will
certainly hear even more praise as
graphene's impact on our lives becomes
more of this so let me refrain from
further praise because today is also an
occasion to celebrate something else the
last decades were relatively peaceful
and quiet for the planet but without no
obvious danger from outside there is
another danger from inside instant
information about everything and
everyone awful
allows an individual opinion to compete
with consensus and paranoia with
evidence it's a time when one honest
blunt statement can finish a lifelong
political career and one opinionated
journalists can bully government or a
royal family science is not immune from
such brushes for example how Nobel Prize
winning experiments how many you think
would have been stopped if ethics and
health and safety regulations at that
time were as zealous as they're today I
can think of more than a few human
progress has always been driven by a
sense of adventure and unconventional
thinking by
amid calls for bread and circuses this
verge
are often forgotten for the sake of
cautiousness and political correctness
that now rules the world and we sink
deeper and deeper from democracy into a
state of mediocrity and even in
theocracy if you want an example don't
look any further than research funding
by the by the European Commission
against this backdrop I salute the
Swedish Royal Academy for keeping the
candle of marital life the great esteem
in which the Nobel Prizes are
universally are universally held is due
to the fact that for several generations
they have been given purely on
scientific merit and not through
lobbying and political or best
presentation I do hope that it will stay
the same way and the prices will never
be given according to the number of
votes in life TV contests
let me also send the royal family for
landing their unwavering support to the
great noble tradition it's a great
feeling to partake in this lavish
celebration that put scientific
achievement on such a high the desktop
the generosity of the Noble Foundation
and all the Swedish people contribute to
making this price so very special from
the very bottom of my heart thank you
you